I've got some bad news we're gonna
practice in a blizzard again even though
we play inside you don't listen do you
you ask do you have any impressive stats
all I have are stats Megatron always
tells me to be like the Lions greats and
retire early
ladies and gentlemen pads that fer
what's the most reliable Ford in Detroit
a staff Ford okay I like that jokes and
I did not like that you want to know how
I got these scars
oh you're combining Joker's I've had a
broken back torn fingerling amends for
my whole career I didn't know if I
existed but I do and other
disenfranchised TVs are starting to
notice
hello Rogers I thought it was something
scary like the Bears good joke before I
used to think the Lions were a tragedy
but now I realize they're a comedy can
you introduce me as Joker no I'm
mediocre can't be Joker can you guys
just let me have one thing hey you
yeah I'll freakin hundred-thousand you
flip listen to me I'll be out about the
anything lurkers watching RBS
so subscribe this Cheney channel GT the
fluff Oh daddy says subscribe